GALLAGHER AND ANDY McCARTHY
ABOUT THE CRYPTO KING.
I THINK WE SPENDS TOO MUCH TIME
CITE SIZES THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK WE CLOSE OUT THIS YEAR
TAKING STOCK OF WHAT IS SO RIGHT
INSTEAD OF WHAT IS TOO WRONG.
THERE HAS BEEN TOO MUCH OF THIS.
>> WE ARE NEVER GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
IT WAS NEVER THAT GREAT.
>> THAT PAST HE'S PROMISING TO
RETURN US TO WAS NEVER AS
ADVERTISED.
>> WHEN DID YOU THINK AMERICA
WAS GREAT.
BRIAN: NICE, RIGHT?
INSTEAD OF US TRYING TO GET OUR
PRONOUNS RIGHT AND MANDATING
REPARATIONS FOR THE HORRORS OF
SLAVERY THAT HAPPENED 200 YEARS
AGO.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS STRIVE TO BE
BETTER AS A NATION AND AS
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE THIS
TIME TO REALIZE HOW MUCH BETTER
WE ARE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY ON
THE PLANET.
FAST FORWARD, A COUPLE DAYS AGO
IN IRAN, A SOCCER SUPERSTAR IS
SENTENCED TO DEATH FOR
PROTESTING FOR THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN.
A PROTEST HAS RAGED IN HIS
COUNTRY FOR MONTHS RESULTING IN
THE DEATHS OF 400 FOR
PROTESTING.
ALL THIS SPURRED ON BECAUSE OF A
22-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WHO WANTED TO
EXPOSE HER HAIR.
THEY KILLED HER.
IN AMERICA YOU STAND UP FOR A
CAUSE.
BUT EVEN AN INJURY IN THE
SMALLEST OR BIGGEST PROTEST IS
NOT TOLERATED IN THIS COUNTRY.
COULD YOU IMAGINE AN ATHLETE IN
THIS COUNTRY BEING HUNG BECAUSE
THEY CAMPAIGNED FOR RIGHTS AND
BASIC FREEDOM?
THE ANSWER IS NO OF COURSE.
WE MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN UPSET ABOUT
MIXED MESSAGING, MANDATES AND
MASKS.
BUT WE NEVER LOCKED DOWN
MILLIONS, WELDING FAMILIES IN
THEIR HOUSES.
RUSSIA, DISPLAYS A BRUTALITY
THAT CONTINUES TO BE REVEALED AT
WAR.
THE COUNTRY HELD OUR FEMALE
SUPERSTAR BASKETBALL PLAYER IN
PRISON FOR A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MARIJUANA.
SHE COULD HAVE BEEN SETS UP.
WE DON'T KNOW THE TRUE STORY
YET.
THEY REFUSED TO SEND HER HOME
UNLESS WE GAVE HER BACK FOR AN
ARMS DEALER.
IN AMERICA WE LOOK TO EXPORT OUR
PRODUCTS THAT MIGHT CHANGE THE
WAY OF LIFE.
WE MAY BE GUILTY OF OPENING TOO
MANY STARBUCKS OR McDONALDS
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT WE'LL NEVER BE GUILTY OF SHY
JACTING ANOTHER COUNTRY'S
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE EASILY
OFFENDS.
BEFORE YOU TAKE TO SOCIAL MEDIA
TO THREATEN THE LIVES OF SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES, MAYBE YOU SHOULD
PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE HOW FREE
THIS COUNTRY IS YOU ARE LIVING
IN.
>> WHEN YOU ARE CALLING TO
ACCOST A BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT,
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S A
CORRECT CHARACTERIZATION.
>> DID NOT TWEET THAT?
THAT YOU THOUGHT THE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES SHOULDN'T
ACCOSTED?
>> THAT'S NOT AN ACCURATE
CHARACTERIZATION OF MY
STATEMENTS.
BRIAN: SHE HAD A RIGHT TO SAY IT
AND A RIGHT TO BE CONFRONTED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO GET UPSET
ABOUT THINGS.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS HERE.
BUT THINGS COULD BE MUCH, MUCH
WORSE ON AMERICA'S WORST DAY.
WE ARE BETTER THAN ANYWHERE ELSE
ON THE PLANET ON THEIR BEST DAY.
WE CAN DISAGREE ON HOW GREAT A
POLICY IS, HOW GREAT A LEADER
IS, BUT